le noble jouer dans les pubs c'est l'un
des vignobles et
l'ancien val de loire puisqu'il ne
compte qu'une vingtaine d'hectares les
vendanges des ces phases finales ne
constituent les cépages précoces ont
débuté le 22 septembre produits sur des
terrains l'ex il donne des vins riches
en alcool
le noble âge où est le fruit d'une
savante alchimie 50 à 60% de tous
on était 30 à 40% le pinot gris pour le
corps c'est lui qui produit l'alcool et
10% pour le pinot noir une vendange
complètement mécanisée ce matin vous
n'avez pas commencer à vendanger de
bonheur pourquoi qu'est ce qui s'est
passé parce que ce matin il a commencé à
tourner de l'eau et il est donc beaucoup
de l'humidité sur le feuillage et la de
machines nous permet d'attendre
elle partit voyez un petit peu de soleil
l'a donc le feuillage et sec ça nous
permet d'atteindre et de le faire
comment relancer là c'est simple c'est
bon un vin que l'on buvait callac your
au moyen-âge oublier pendant des lustres
il vit sa renaissance depuis 1975
les lionceaux auraient importé les
cépages de bourgogne ici on sent surtout
de paix s'il est tout s'est étendu tout
autour de joué les tours revenant
jusqu'à èvre et donc on a un dossier
actuellement en appellation pour
demander de l'appellation touraine noble
jouer qui est à paris et on s'appuie
beaucoup sur l'historique un vignoble
qui pourrait être étendue seulement
voilà ce n'est pas du tout la
réglementation européenne
alors les producteurs font aujourd'hui
dans la recherche de la qualité
cette année ils ont abondamment palier
dans les rimes pour haïr et les grappes
au détriment de la quantité
alors comment s'annonce le noble jouer
93 pour l'instant c'est encore un peu
tôt de le dire c'est en des relâches
mais les degrés est très bon là
actuellement son être ce matin ça tourne
autour de 11
on a trouvé jusqu'à rangs ennemis ont ce
set donc c'est déjà bien il ya
énormément de couleurs les pellicules
des raisins est raide
elle est très épaisse et c'est ce qu'ils
vont tient dans tout le tous les arômes
toute la couleur et quand ça fermente ça
dégage énormément d'arômes de fraises de
grenadine cette année très intéressant
mais ça demande à être confirmé
traditionnellement grille de nombreux
jouets 93 sera un peu plus coloré que la
normale sa commercialisation le
particulier les aussi la restauration
locale et il part à l'exportation vers
la belgique l'angleterre plane bailly
l'as olemps